- [Sal] So all organisms
need food to survive.
Now, for some of you, this
might be pretty obvious.
You realize what might happen to your body
if you don't get food.
You might realize that you
need that food for both energy
and you need that to actually
build up your actual body.
So you need it for matter as well.
But some of you might be thinking,
all right, I have a mouth.
I understand where the food goes.
I also understand what's left over
when I'm done with the food.
And so I must have extracted
some energy and matter from it,
but you just said all organisms, Sal,
and I'm looking outside of a window
and I see a tree and a
tree does not have a mouth.
A tree is an organism.
How does it get its food?
And the answer you might already realize
is that the tree
can make its own food
through photosynthesis.
We've seen this in other videos.
You have carbon dioxide in
the air and you have water.
And the presence of energy
in the form of sunlight,
through the process of
photosynthesis, would produce glucose
and molecular oxygen as a byproduct.
And you can count the various carbons
that are in this dark gray color.
Oxygen's in this red
color and hydrogen's here.
And you can see that
everything all adds up.
You have one, two, three,
four, five six carbons here
in the six carbon dioxide molecules.
And then you could see in this glucose,
you have one, two, three,
four, five, six carbons.
I encourage you to pause the video
and make sure that the
oxygens are all accounted for
between the glucose molecule
and this molecular oxygen,
and that the hydrogens
are all accounted for.
And so a plant can produce its own food,
and then when they need it,
they can metabolize that food
through a process of respiration.
It's really important to realize
that respiration does
not just occur in your
and my bodies.
Even organisms like plants
need to break down the food
that they produced if they
wanna use it for energy.
Now, the question you might have is,
where is the energy here?
Just as it takes energy
to rearrange these atoms
and molecules into glucose,
under the right conditions,
through a metabolic pathway,
you can go the other way around.
And chemically, that will release
energy, which even a plant
which isn't running around,
it isn't doing jumping jacks,
it isn't talking.
It needs energy just to be alive.
All living things need
energy in order to exist,
in order to maintain their
cells, in order to reproduce.
So many of you all have
probably heard the term
carbohydrate when we're
thinking about food
or when we're thinking
about an energy context.
And it's important to note
that this glucose molecule here
is an example of a carbohydrate.
It's not the only example of it,
but one question might be,
why is it even called a carbohydrate?
Well, when you break
down the different parts,
it seems like it would involve carbon.
Right over here, you have the carbo part.
And it seems like it's somehow
involving water: carbohydrate.
And that's because early chemists,
they didn't actually
understand the structure
of a carbohydrate the way that we do now.
All they saw was the
ratio between the carbons,
the hydrogens and the oxygens.
That for every carbon.
So let's say there are N carbons,
there's going to be
twice as many hydrogens,
and N oxygens as well.
So one thing, one way to think about it,
for every single carbon, you have an H2O.
So every carbon, you have a water.
So that's why early chemists,
when they saw this ratio,
they called it carbohydrates.
Glucose is a very simple carbohydrate,
but you can make up chains
of things like glucose
to build up more complex carbohydrates.
Now it's important to realize
that these types of molecules
aren't just used for energy.
They can also be used for matter.
The more that you study biochemistry,
you're going to see a lot
of different molecules
that are made up of these building blocks
of carbons, oxygens, and hydrogens.
And sometimes you might
even recognize structures
that look a little bit like glucose,
or look like things that
have been put together
from some of these basic building blocks.
For example, this molecule right over here
is known as thymidine monophosphate,
and it's a fancy name.
But you can look at the
building blocks here.
The monophosphate, you
have a phosphate group
right over here.
Thymidine comes from this
part of the molecule.
It's sometimes known as a nitrogenous base
because it has nitrogen that
you see in blue over here.
And then right over here,
connecting the pieces,
you have a five carbon sugar: Ribose.
Now glucose is a six carbon sugar,
Ribose is a five carbon sugar,
but there are metabolic pathways
where you can go from five carbon sugars
to six carbon sugars, and back and forth.
And what's interesting
about things like thymidine monophosphate
is it is a building block for something
that is very, very, very important: DNA.
Thymidine monophosphate is a nucleotide
with a nitrogenous base thymine.
You put a bunch of these
nucleotides together,
not all of them have a
nitrogenous base of thymine here,
but they form this double
helix structure that we study
in a lot of depth in
many, many other videos.
And you might already realize that DNA
is the molecular basis of inheritance.
We could not be who we are
without these types of molecules.
Now, what's also
interesting is how do these
different constituent
molecules rearrange themselves,
even in the presence of energy,
to make other molecules?
Or to get energy, how do
they re-rearrange themselves
to release that energy?
And all of these metabolic
pathways are facilitated
by what are known as enzymes.
And just to give an example of an enzyme
this big thing here is commonly known
as the Rubisco enzyme.
Now you don't have to know its name
at this point in your careers,
but this is one of the enzymes
in the metabolic pathways
that's able to take carbon dioxide
and attach it to another molecule
that eventually can get us to
forming a glucose molecule.
And what happens here is
the various constituents
attach to different
parts of these enzymes.
And these enzymes change
their shape as they attach
to certain things and they
can jam things together.
They can synthesize other molecules
or they can even help to break them apart.
And it all comes full circle
because the enzymes
themselves, these are proteins.
These are made up of amino acids,
which themselves are made up
of a lot of these building block molecules
that contain your carbons, your oxygens,
and your hydrogens in them.
I'll let you go now.
But the important thing is to realize
is that we have whole universes occurring
in our cells, and that
all of these molecules
and biological systems are
connected in different ways.
And you have a whole series
of metabolic pathways that are facilitated
by enzymes that take one set
of things and step-by-step,
put them together or break them apart
in order to do all of the
different biological functions
that we know are necessary for life.